on November 4 2009 teen former boy band
member and current fashion icon Harry
Styles posted an image to Twitter within
24 hours it racked up over half a
million likes it was the cover to his
long awaited sophomore album and fans
dissected every last detail from the
pink and blue color palette which was
used for the studio backdrop his custom
Gucci outfit and was even painted on his
fingernails too this disembodied hand in
the corner which belongs to Tim Walker
the photographer and finally the
scandalous release date Friday December
13th his ex-girlfriend Taylor Swift's
birthday but zoom out to the whole image
and you'll see something that extends
far beyond the world of Harry Styles
fandom this circular photograph is the
latest in a long line of album covers
that have that same warped composition
this is a story of musics obsession with
the fish islands in 1906 renowned
physicist Robert W Wood was in his lab
at Johns Hopkins University with a
bucketful of water a pinhole camera
mirrored glass and a lot of light he
wanted to see if he could create an
image of the world from the perspective
of a fish whose view from underwater
compresses the entire horizon this
experiment might seem unusual but wood
was a professor of optical physics and
he dedicated his career to inventing the
unconventional tools to study light from
developing this disk whose microscopic
components helped determine the age of
stars 2 inventing this toy which
according to the patent created
grotesque images of people's faces
through a series of perfectly placed
mirrors
I first heard of him as being sort of an
offbeat
kind of guy that often had a deep
insight into things in kind of a quirky
way that's John beaver a photographer
who is also a professor of physics and
astronomy that basic diagram of the race
coming in at different angles and I mean
I teach that all the time it's in every
beginning physics book but the idea of
making a camera out of that in this
paper would detailed what he wanted to
see
he says the circular picture would
contain everything embraced within an
angle of 180 degrees in every direction
ie the complete Hemisphere and luckily
he left us with a set of instructions
[Music]
let's get another one of those clamps in
case of contact flash scanner eyes with
water for at least 60 minutes I honestly
have no idea how the hell he did this I
think there's an easy way for you to do
it now that he couldn't have done you
can just goddamnit can we just cut to
the pictures this is a picture he took
from under a bridge this is a lineup of
men and this is what a fish might see if
all those men were looking down at it
from above the surface of a pond soon
researchers and scientists built on
Woods idea from 1915 through the 1930s
it was the fields of meteorology and
astronomy that drove the development of
a camera lens that could capture that
coveted fisheye perspective and on the
eve of world war ii german inventors
filed a patent furlings which they then
shared with the Japanese company Nikon
the lens used the same principles as
woods water experiment now you can see
it right in his diagram with the bucket
does the light rays come in earnest
bangle they come out at a less steep
angle and so light rays that are coming
from huge angles are compressed onto the
picture in 1957 Nikon produced their
first special order fisheye camera
factoring in inflation it was a twenty
seven thousand dollar piece of gear
though they were still primarily used
for scientific research
a few caught the attention of magazine
and newspaper photographers this 1957
issue of Life magazine shows a fisheye
view of a Senate hearing a few months
later that same camera photographed a
pole-vaulter mid jump and in 1962 sixty
years after Robert Woods original
experiment nikons first consumer grade
fisheye lens
hit the market and it became a
pop-culture phenomenon the captured
baseball stadiums shark Kage's political
conventions the Apollo trainings and
launches and protests it was and always
has been a handy tool to capture tight
quarters as well as huge spaces but
perhaps its greatest strength was making
rock stars appear larger than life when
the Beatles kicked off the British
Invasion in the mid 1960s the fish
Islands was uniquely suited to document
the insanity here they are at a Miami
press conference and during a TV
performance
the lenses warped perspective reflected
the trip eNOS of the psychedelic era
including at the Woodstock Music
Festival
[Music]
this is jazz musician Sam reverse 1965
album fuchsia swing song and it's one of
the earliest fisheye album covers a few
months later The Byrds released mr.
Tambourine Man over the next few years
fisheye album art cemented itself in
music the most common format was this a
giant circular fisheye lens portrait of
the artist or band with typography above
and below it and more Illustrated
approaches the font wraps fully around
the image and some exclude the artist
altogether opting to show an interesting
scene or landscape oh I just thought of
a fisheye album cover do you know we're
just read about Mike Oldfield no but I'm
gonna look it up right now oh wow that's
really cool the fisheye lens was a go-to
piece of gear for music photographers
and filmmakers by the end of the 1970s
it was there for concerts television
performances in photo shoots so by the
time MTV launched in 1981 it was pretty
much inevitable that the super wide
angle lens would play a huge role in
music videos
it could get super close to a performer
while still capturing the space around
them this is a music video for the
Beastie Boys track shake your rump it
was shot with at least three cameras
equipped with a fisheye lens the fisheye
worked for every genre from 60s hippies
to alt rock but hip-hop had a sense of
humor and it was in your face which
helped turn the fisheye into one of the
genres signature looks and in the 90s
that's thanks to director Mike Williams
from 1991 to 1999 he directed dozens of
music videos for top artists and many of
those prominently featured a fisheye
perspective Busta Rhymes TLC and of
course Missy Elliott the list goes on
and on and let's not forget those
fisheye album covers the fisheye lens is
no doubt a novelty when you see a photo
taken with it your eye will likely first
focus on the highly distorted style of
the image and then register what's in it
but that under sells how timeless and
useful of a tool it actually is one
generation might see it as a psychedelic
photography trope another a 1990s
hip-hop throwback if you're an
astronomer it helps you track clouds
moving across the atmosphere and the
terrain on the surface of Mars
and if you're as curious as Robert would
it'll let you see the world from the
point of view of a fish
[Music]